Hey youtubers it's Charlie and yesterday in
my Korra video I asked you all to submit Questions
so I picked a bunch to answer in this video
so we could follow up on some of the really
big stuff. Lots of Zaheer Airbending Disciple
talk. All very interesting.
Real quick shoutout to Omaster and Ninja DC,
you guys are the winners from yesterday's
giveaway. I'll be messaging you on your channel
for details. You basically win amazon gift
cards.
The next round of the giveaway will start
when I post my episode 6 and 7 video next
Friday. All you have to do to participate
is be a subscriber and leave a comment.
If you guys ever wondered why it's tied to
comments it's actually because the most valuable
thing you can do to help me is leave a comment.
It's how I learn how you feel about something.
Comments are where the community lives. And
that's really the thing I care about the most.
So that's why.
Speaking of comments, let's do some questions.
Careful for spoilers from this week's episodes
if you haven't seen them yet. I'll wait just
a sec...Okay, here we go.
Question 1 - Lukas asks will we see a civil
war in the earth kingdom (people against the
queen)?
Usually there are multiple conflicts that
either overlap or go happen at the same time
during the finale. Like Korra will have her
battle with the Team Zaheer plot and there
will be some sort of human versus human conflict.
Based on what we've seen so far, I don't see
anyone else becoming the villain of that human
conflict. So yes to the Earth Queen versus
her people. I don't know if it will just turn
out to be a straight up civil war, but no
one will be killing anyone. That's not really
what Korra is about and it wouldn't fit with
the Airbending philosophy that all life is
sacred.
The Earth Queen was subjigating all her citizens
yes, not just Airbenders, but I think it would
be really cool if we saw those Earth Kingdom
airbenders return to Ba Sing Se to help make
peace.
The Earth Queen is a lot like the Queen of
Hearts from Alice in Wonderland. Really over
the top crazy and comical. But I think there
are a couple ways her plot could resolve itself.
One would be for Korra and the Airbenders
to teach her the error of her ways, or some
of her power could be taken away and the Earth
Kingdom could appoint a parliment. Like what
happened in the UK. The monarchy still exists,
but over the last 100 years, the royal family
has slowly given more and more of their decision
making power to the government.
To the point where Queen Elizabeth is more
of a figurehead and Parliment does the day
to day job of making sure species 456 doesn't
kill everyone. Shout out to all the torchwood
fans.
Question 2 - Camile asks what was so important
about Korra that Team Zaheer couldn't do it
with Aang when he was still alive?
Good question, so Korra is almost 19 right
now. So let's assume Team Zaheer was put in
prison the year she was born. They look like
they're about the same age as Tenzin, so they
would have been in their early 30s when they
were arrested.
I can think of two big reasons why they'd
go for Korra versus Aang. The first is that
Aang was dying by the time they put their
plan together. Like Aang was in his final
years and either wouldn't have had enough
strength to do whatever Zaheer wanted the
avatar to do OR if they're just trying to
convince the avatar to help them, Aang was
too stuck in his ways and would have never
agreed to their mystery plan.
I think it's a combination of those two things.
They saw Aang was on his way out, so they
thought it would be easier to raise a new
avatar teaching her their philosophy, so Korra
would make things the way they wanted.
That's kind of a twist on what Unalaq wanted,
except he wanted to kill Raava. I don't think
that's what Zaheer wants. There's still too
much we don't know about him to guess what
his plan is.
I'm just going to call it his mystery plan
until Zaheer does an evil guy monologue explaining
it all.
Question 3 - Wargaming (no avatar) asks Where
did Zuko's Dragon come from?
In the Dragon Days comic, Aang saves the last
Dragon egg. I'm assuming it's either the dragon
that hatched from that Egg. During Last Airbender
they learned Iroh had protected Ran and Shaw
too.
We learned in that Zuko video game Nickelodeon
released on their website that his dragon's
name is Druk. He was born around 18 years
ago. Meaning it's about the same age as Korra.
It's funny to think that the birth of Zuko's
Dragon and the birth of a new Avatar are connected.
But I can see why they would connect those
two big events. I'm sure there are a lot of
big things that were connected to Korra's
birth. Including Zaheer's mystery plot.
The takeaway is that Druk is probably the
progeny of the dragons from last airbender
or his egg was laid when Firelord Sozin was
killing them all and just survived to hatch
when Korra was born.
I've always thought that dragon eggs take
forever to hatch, just because in all the
different fantasy series I've ever seen. Dragons
are an extremely long-lived race.
Question 4 - Benjamin asks Do you think Aang
was the one that taught Zaheer about Airbending?
Yes it's definitely possible. I saw a lot
of you guys speculating that Zaheer was an
early air disciple when Tenzin was growing
up and learned about something dangerous and
tried to do something crazy. Aang took his
bending away and then years later when Zaheer
tried to kidnap Korra they were all locked
away.
Making this like his third try to do whatever
he's trying to do. And Harmonic Convergence
restored his bending that Aang took away.
It would explain why he's so good. And there
wouldn't have been many people other than
aang who could have taught him about airbending
30 or forty years ago.
Question 5 - Andre asks do you think Opals
actually Lin's daughter?
No, I don't think it's going to be that complicated.
I think that the whole Lin Suyin backstory
is going to be a simple take on their big
differences. Like Beifong trying to be super
responsible and strict and Suyin being rebellious
and getting away with everything.
Suyin said that Toph wasn't super proud of
either one of them in the end, but Lin is
probably just bitter about Suyin never being
held to account for her actions.
That explanation makes Lin seem like more
of an emotional child in that she can't just
get over the fact they see the world differently.
But I think we're meant to draw some similarities
in the way Lin and the Earth Queen are both
behaving ridiculously and need to open their
eyes.
Lin is a good person, so I think she'll get
there eventually.
Question 6 - Kevin (no avatar) asks Maybe
the real antagonists are the White Lotus?
I think the real antagonist is ignorance.
Like all the characters will have to get used
to change and that's the real obstacle to
overcome. Zaheer just seems like the villain
right now because his plan takes him in opposition
to Team Avatar.
The White Lotus people we've seen so far this
season haven't done anything that make the
villains. They're really just following Zuko's
orders at this point and Zuko isn't the villain.
It sounds silly but they'll all probably get
to the point this season when a real change
will come and everyone in the world will just
have to learn to deal. It kind of already
happened with Harmonic Convergence. But Zaheer
could always be trying to bond the physical
realm with the spirit realm in a much bigger
way.
That spirit Korra almost hit in Republic City
said we're all the same, even the avatar should
know that. It just sounds very ominous to
me, like everyone really will become the same
in a much more obvious way.
Question 7 - Chivaugh asks Is it just me or
has the Dai Li and White Lotus gotten less
badass?
I think they just want to make the new characters,
Kai and Team Zaheer, seem like bigger badasses.
They're more of a threat if they can take
down the White Lotus and the Dai Li.
And since the world hasn't really been at
war in a huge global way since Aang's time,
people might have gone a little soft. So the
Dai Li and the White Lotus could both be more
like maintenance level benders, not the kind
of superhero epic benders you see emerge during
times
of war.
Question 8 - Danny Phantom asks Do you think
Zaheer's Void has something to do with the
original Airbenders?
Not necessarily, but I do think it has to
do with energy bending and transcending physical
existence. I know I mentioned conquering death
in my last video, but the best way to do that
would be to exist as pure energy. That might
not be what Zaheer is trying to do exactly.
But I don't think he's just trying to contact
someone.
I think he's trying to energy bend everyone
or some twist on the astral state we've seen
Korra and Aang go into when they get super
Zen. Guru Pathik's Chakra's might get referenced
again.
Question 9 - iloveme asks Why did Nick take
all the episodes down off Nick.com?
Probably because they want to try to increase
live ratings for Korra. I don't think it will
work and I don't think that their strategy
of not putting episodes on itunes quickly
is going to work either. Right now the only
way to watch the show legally is to watch
it on Nickelodeon. But if you live in a country
where Nick isn't available which is most places.
It really hurts their viewership.
It's a whole big thing. So my sympathies to
anyone who's having trouble watching new episodes.
I can't allow any streaming links in the comments
here, just because they are illegal, but that's
typically the only way to find Korra episodes.
There's currently no legal streaming options
available.
Number 10 and last one, Scott in the comments
pointed out some of the really cool voice
actors Avatar has had in the past and this
season so I wanted to read his comment. Since
I haven't done a video just about the casting.
Some of these people you may have already
recognized.
Jack DeSena was Sokka on Last Airbender, he
doesn't have any Korra credits on IMDB
Eva Marie Saint is old Katara on Korra. JK
Simmons everyone knows as shirtless Tenzin.
Mindy Sterling as Chief Cranky Pants Lin Beifong,
DB Sweeney as old Aang on Korra.
Anne Heche is the new Suyin Beifong character,
Lisa Edelstein you probably remember from
last season as Kya. Dante Basco was young
Zuko on Last Airbender and Zuko's grandson
Iroh on Korra
Mark Hamill was Firelord Ozai, Grey DeLisle
was young Azula and is now doing the armless
waterbender P'Li on Korra.
And Henry Rollins is playing Zaheer.
Nickelodeon for some reason never did a big
casting announcement for the new Book 3 voice
actors, but they're really cool additions
to the already giant list of awesome Avatar
people.
So next week there's two more episodes again,
6 and 7. I think they're going to resolve
the Metal Bending city story and move on to
something new.
Since those two episodes will basically be
the halfway point of the season I'm hoping
we finally get an explanation of what Zaheer
is trying to do. I know everyone wants to
know what Toph is up to, but I don't think
they'll explain that anytime soon.
I have seen a really cool theory on the Red
Lotus as a possible alternative antagonist
as it relates to the Pai Sho game. I don't
have a lot of information about that, so if
something develops I'll include it in a future
video.
Right now click here for my review of the
episodes and click here for my top 10 last
airbender characters.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tonight.
High Fives!